das ist zdf heute live herzlich
willkommen rechte provokateure haben
gestern im bundestag abgeordnete
bedrängt und videos davon im netz
gepostet das netz war voll davon
inzwischen nicht mehr so ganz denn
vieles davon ist auch wieder gelöscht es
gibt zum beispiel eines mit
wirtschaftsminister peter altmaier das
schauen wir uns an
[Musik]
könig wir immer noch im büro von herrn
udo himmel an jesus man muss man ja
immer erklären auch an dieser stelle mit
ronny könig ist wohl so was wie
möchtegern könig gemeint und der
abgeordnete in dessen büro hier gefilmt
wurde heißt korrekt rudow himmel garen
von der afd der inzwischen auch
zugegeben hat ja ich habe diese leute
eingeladen aber er behauptet er habe
vorher abgesprochen dass er keine
kompromittierenden videos haben möchte
die frage ist dann nur warum lädt man
rechte youtuber in den bundestag ein
und die große frage ist jetzt welche
konsequenzen hat das
ich freue mich auf eure fragen und
kommentare wie immer in die kommentare
oder wenn ihr die zdf wollte app nutzt
diese e mail adresse nutzen unser
hauptstadtkorrespondent starbett de padt
ist heute abend bei uns zugeschaltet aus
berlin
da wird du bist nicht nur
hauptstadtkorrespondent sondern du hast
auch in bestimmten schwerpunkt denn du
bericht ist viel über die afd
wie hast du wir haben die abgeordneten
im reichstag heute diesen tag danach
erlebt ja das war wahrscheinlich kann
man das mit katerstimmung ganz gut
beschreiben zumindest bei den
abgeordneten der parteien die ich auch
die heißen
juni fielen nach also ich war vorhin
selbst im bundestag unterwegs und da hat
man dann auch abgeordnete getroffen die
berichtet haben und die hatten zum teil
lange gesichter
und fast jeder hat irgendwie eine
geschichte zu erzählen von mitarbeitern
oder von sich selbst was er gestern
erlebt hatte also geschichten zum
beispiel dass mails hin und her
geschickt wurde zwischen den büros man
solle von innen abschließen weil eben
aktivisten da in den schulen unterwegs
sein das hatte man so vorher nicht
gehabt einer berichtete zum beispiel ein
mitarbeiter sei auf dem weg gewesen zu
ihm einen koffer mit auch
geheimdienstlich relevanten dokumenten
und ist dann auch ich habe vor der tür
des reichstags dann in so eine gruppe
zusammen gestoßen die ihnen da bedrängt
haben
und dann diese order über diesen koffer
ins gebäude bekommen das ist dann auch
gut gegangen aber es gibt auf jeden fall
viele beispiele dafür dass das gestern
ein ganz besonderer tag im
bundestagswahl bundestag war der glaube
ich vielen da noch lange nachhängen wird
zusammengefasst für verschiedene heute
formate verschiedene stücke für
verschiedene heute formate in 1 schauen
wir mal rein
am tag danach sitzt die entrüstung noch
tief bei vielen abgeordneten und
mitarbeitern des bundestags über
vorgänge im haus die so einmalig wie
verstörend sein dass leute sich in büros
einschließen müssen weil sie angst haben
da rede ich jetzt von mitarbeiterinnen
und mitarbeitern
wir haben offensichtlich den fall
gewesen dass versucht wurde den
abgeordnetenbüros namentlich in denen
des spd-fraktionsvorsitzenden
einzudringen was sind das für zustände
eigentlich es sind sehen wie diese die
empören corona leutner und einschlägig
bekannte rechte aktivisten laufen über
die flure des bundestags bedrängen und
beleidigen parlamentarier durch die
sicherheitsschleuse gelotst von
einzelnen abgeordneten der fdp fraktion
es waren gäste von zwei abgeordneten
dabei muss ich allerdings sagen und das
tut mir sehr leid dass zwei der gäste
sich der kontrolle durch die einladen
entzogen haben und dabei sind dinge
vorgefallen die ich zutiefst bedauern
mittag tagte sogenannte ältestenrat des
bundestags dem vertreter aller parteien
angehören alle außer der afg sind sich
später einig es muss konsequenzen geben
strafrechtlich sind diese verfahren wo
sind diese vorgänge gestern aus unserer
sicht auch relevant es geht hier um die
bedrängung von abgeordneten eine davon
ist auch noch minister so peter altmaier
bei der ausübung ihrer tätigkeit und wir
sammeln
all diese vorfälle jetzt wollen sie
gemeinsam dann der staatsanwaltschaft
auch übergeben morgen soll es im plenum
eine aktuelle stunde dazu geben die
aufarbeitung fängt erst an wenn ich in
die community kugel da gibt es leute die
sich sehr über die aktion aufregend es
gibt aber auch welche die zum beispiel
wie carsten rampe entschuldigung wie
markus schweikert über facebook
schreiben
man macht aus einer ameise mal wieder
einen elefanten
wir kommen mal direkt zu der frage
welche konsequenzen das denn haben kann
da schreibt carsten rampe auf facebook
ich hoffe es gibt strafrechtliche
konsequenzen und konkret an die frage in
die frage nach den abgeordneten da fragt
der user theoretisch über youtube was
für eine strafe kann es für die
abgeordneten welche die störer
eingeladen haben geben
ja ich habe gerade die fragen bisschen
abgehackt gehört richter habe ich hab
genug verstanden um zu antworten also
das ist doch mal kurz die mücke und
elefanten das hängt auch damit zusammen
dass wir jetzt so groß darüber berichten
viele medien groß darüber berichten dass
der bundestag eben ein ganz besonderer
ort ist nicht irgendein gebäude sondern
da sitzt sozusagen die höchste die
wichtigste institution in diesem land
und die abgeordneten genießen da auch in
ganz besonderen schutz
das soll auch so sein das muss auch so
sein das geht auch zurück wie zum
beispiel in die 30er jahre als im
damaligen reichstag
leute ein und ausging und da im
abgeordnete damals und der druck gesetzt
haben ohne wer jetzt eine parallele
direkt zu ziehen aber nur zu um zu
verstehen das ist also ein ganz
besonderer ort und der anspruch ist eben
daher dass abgeordnete ihr mandat da
wirklich frei und ohne direkte
beeinflussung da vor ort ausüben können
und das war eben gestern aus der sicht
vieler abgeordneter jedenfalls anders
weil da bei einer abstimmung oder vor
einer abstimmung eben einfluss genommen
versucht wurde zu nehmen und das ist
jetzt auch der grund warum über wirklich
zum teil deutliche konsequenzen
nachgedacht wird
für diese youtuber rechten aktivisten da
ist von möglicher nötigung die rede wenn
man mit abgeordneten des ältestenrats
spricht da könnte es tatsächlich sein
dass das strafrecht strafrechtliche
ermittlungen folgen eben weil die
abgeordneten bei ihrer ausübung des
mandats nicht behindert werden dürfen
und das könnte tatsächlich in diesem
fall beeinträchtigung sein
dieser paragraf 106 ist das und da wird
man jetzt abwarten die sammeln im moment
noch das sagten auch viele abgeordnete
und gucken was kommt wir am ende
zusammen wer welcher mitarbeiter welche
abgeordnete berichtet was von dem
gestrigen tag welche qualität hat das
dann auch insgesamt und dann wird das an
die staatsanwaltschaft wohl übergeben
und dann wird ermittelt was die
abgeordneten der af die betrifft die die
aktivisten die dann später diese unruhe
brachten ins haus gelassen haben als
gäste auch ganz legal so zu sagen haben
dann aber zum teil die aufsichtspflicht
die sie dann in dem moment eigentlich
gehabt hätten die zu begleiten oder
begleiten zu lassen
vernachlässigt und da wird jetzt auch
geprüft also die die anderen fraktionen
die parlamentarischen geschäftsführer
der anderen parteien sind stinksauer
also das habe ich auch selten erlebt in
dieser qualität wieder heute berichtet
wurde auch von dieser
ältestenratssitzung da hieß es auch
jetzt sei das vertrauen mit der afg
zusammenzuarbeiten endgültig
aufgebraucht und der wird jetzt geschaut
ob man auch direkte sanktionen oder
konsequenzen für diese auf die
abgeordneten
treffen kann das sieht die
geschäftsordnung sagt uns wolfgang
kubicki vor einem interview eigentlich
nicht vor weil man sich das nicht hätte
vorstellen können dieses szenario aber
auch in die geschäftsordnung könnte man
noch mal ran und auch das wird in den
nächsten tagen vielleicht wochen geprüft
ich habe mir gerade die anregung von
frank walter hubertus über youtube auf
der nochmal fragt was es passierten
bitte noch einmal kurze zusammenfassung
und nutze das gleichzeitig als ton check
für david kannst du mich störungsfrei
hören oder sind die aussetzer immer noch
da also ich höre ist mit aussetzern
leider okay dann fasse ich das noch
einmal kurz zusammen und versuche dann
irgendwie eine frage an dich nach berlin
zu übermitteln deren kernpunkte du
verstehen kannst es geht um das was
gestern im bundestag passiert ist rechte
youtuber haben dort vereinzelt
abgeordnete bedrängt sie zu ihrem
abstimmungsverhalten gefragt und jetzt
ist die frage wie sind sie dort
hineingekommen warum waren sie nicht
begleitet obwohl sie das eigentlich
hätten sein müssen und um diese
aufarbeitung dieses vorfalls geht es
jetzt heute
david ich lese die fragen mal vor und
formuliert die frage an dich dann ganz
kurz jürgen tonn ist schreibt auf
facebook der ard typ wusste vorher genau
was die machen würden war so gewollt und
gilbert und grau schreibt über facebook
auch jetzt bedauert diese partei das
verhalten ihrer gäste glaubt den kein
wort lügner und betrüger werden niemals
klüger david wie schätzt du das
verhalten der parteispitze heute ein die
sich ja distanziert hat wie bewertest du
das ja das war interessant so auf die
verhältnisse auch das einerseits eine
sehr klare entschuldigung kam von
alexander gauland in fraktionschef
das macht er auch nicht gerne und nicht
oft aber andererseits auch relativierung
der ganzen geschichte zum beispiel die
szene mit den altmaier hatten wir ja
gesehen die endet ja mit ich jetzt
eigentlich gar nicht wiederholen also
wirklich einer unflätigen beleidigungen
ganz zum schluss als er in dem aufzug
fährt und
darauf angesprochen sagte also die auf
die fraktionsspitze heute na ja da war
die tür ja zu daher hat er das
wahrscheinlich gar nicht mehr gehört so
schlimm kann das also nicht gewesen sein
und es wird eben auch die verantwortung
für die abgeordneten zumindest auch wenn
auf die fraktionsspitzen seite
relativierte hätten sich gäste quasi
also selbstständig irgendwie ausgetobt
und ja auch die hätte man besser achten
müssen aber die verantwortung sehen sie
schon eher bei diesen abgeordnete bei
diesen gästen bei diesen aktivisten aber
wir werden sehen morgen ist eine
fraktions sondersitzung einberufen
morgen früh direkt von der fdp
fraktionsspitze
einziger tagesordnungspunkt die
vorkommnisse gestern und wie das alles
passieren könnte da wird sich bestimmt
für unmut auch bahn brechen
vielleicht auch applaus also da ist die
fdp fraktion und ich auch die partei
insgesamt auch ziemlich gespalten muss
man sagen es ich habe mit einigen
abgeordneten gesprochen die einen oder
anderen fanden die aktion eigentlich gut
hilft uns doch und auch solche
formulierungen wie warum ist man jetzt
da ich so zart besaitet und letztendlich
mobilisiert dass unsere leute aber eben
auch abgeordnete die sagen das ist mir
total peinlich so eine aktion
verschreckt bürgerliche wähler die wir
eigentlich erreichen wollen
da haben wir uns sachen die kollegen ein
bei uns einen bärendienst erwiesen also
da ist auch innerhalb der fdp fraktion
ein geteiltes meinungsbild und das wird
morgen dieser fraktionssitzung
sicherlich kontrovers auch diskutiert
und auch ob es tatsächlich konsequenzen
für diese abgeordneten gibt es eigene
art von rüge gibt ob es eine frau die
sich verpflichten sollen solche aktionen
nicht zu wiederholen oder ob das dann
letztendlich irgendwie nach einer
aussprache auch wieder zu ende ist
vielleicht noch ganz kurz diese
zusammenarbeit von teilen der afg und
auch teilen der fdp abgeordneten mit
rechten youtube an und aktivisten die
gibt es auch schon länger dass gestern
nicht das erste mal die fdp-fraktion
oder abgeordnete der fraktion
organisieren immer wieder auch so
genannte alternative medien konnte
in heißen die in den räumen des
bundestags wo eben ganz gezielt auch
aktivisten dieses schlags von gestern
sag ich mal und auch andere da
zusammenkommen und man gemeinsam
strategien entwickelt also das ist schon
ein verhältnis was was es schon länger
gibt und was auch gepflegt wird von
einigen zumindest das ist ein gutes
stichwort für mich denn ich würde dich
gerne auch noch nachdem fragen was vor
dem reichstag passiert ist du warst da
gestern als journalist du hast berichtet
von den demonstrationen die vor dem
reichstag stattgefunden haben wie
beschreibst du die situation da was hast
du da erlebt ja es war ich war auch im
august schon da in der august war ja
auch so eine nach eine größere
demonstration in berlin und das hat sich
dann gestern etwas fortgesetzt nämlich
ich habe vor allem den blick eben auf
die auch die bundestagsabgeordneten in
dem fall wir haben auch kollegen geht
die demo insgesamt oder die anderen
fokus haben ich habe ein bisschen den
fokus und kokos passiert da gerade
zwischen afd und den demonstrierenden
und da kann man sagen dass da schon im
schulterschluss stattfindet es sind
viele abgeordnete im august gestern auch
wieder dazu gekommen manche sagen sie
gucken sie das nur an bei manchen würde
ich sagen das sind wirklich auch
teilnehmer dieser demonstration und ich
habe schon das gefühl dass die mehrheit
langsam in der afg sich eher so als
parlamentarische arm dieser proteste
auch verstehen will auch wieder nicht
alle
man kann auch mit auf die abgeordneten
und auch bundesvorstandsmitglied
sprechen die davor warnen zu sehr zu eng
mit dieser im der monster mit dieser
bewegung mit den querdenkern zu
verschmelzen die sagen abstand wie
gesagt auch wieder da das verschreckt
bürgerliche wähler das hilft uns nicht
umfragen zeigen es gibt auch einen
beachtlichen teil an fd wählern
sympathisanten die sich er strengere
maßnahmen oder die maßnahme nannte
corona maßnahmen okay finden also da ist
anders als in der flüchtlings thematik
die partei nicht so gemeint also da gibt
es auch welche die sagen abstand halten
aber ich hab so ein bisschen das gefühl
der mainstream dieser partie
sagt mittlerweile das sind unsere
verbündeten auf der straße da müssen wir
uns blicken lassen
das da ist potenzial auch für
mobilisierung bei kommenden wahlen und
dass die afg so ein bisschen die anti
corona partei sozusagen noch mehr werden
will als sie es schon den letzten wochen
und monaten auch geworden ist dann sage
ich an dieser stelle vielen dank lieber
damit dass du dir heute abend zeit
genommen hast für zdf heute live
dankeschön für deine eindrücke und
einschätzungen aus berlin und wir
blicken mal auf die straße gestern und
schauen uns an die bilder die man
gesehen hat gestern rund um das
reichstagsgebäude es waren laut polizei
7000 demonstranten unterwegs
die dort vor der tür lautstark
demonstriert haben viele haben sich
nicht an die regeln gehalten weshalb die
polizei schließlich die demonstration
aufgelöst
wir sprechen darüber weiter mit
katharina nock und sie ist
politikwissenschaftlerin kennt sich sehr
gut aus in der szene hat zusammen mit
pia lamberti ein buch geschrieben das
den titel trägt fake facts wie
verschwörungstheorien unser denken
bestimmen
schönen guten abend schön dass sie bei
uns sind wie bewerten sie das was sie
gestern vor und im reichstag gesehen
haben ja so schläft man muss ich sagen
ich bin zwar berlinerin aber ich bin
tatsächlich nicht zur demonstration
gegangen das hat einen ganz persönlichen
hintergrund als jemand der sich mit
verschwörungs ideologien beschäftigt bin
ich einfach mit sehr vielen drohungen
konfrontiert da war fiel die
entscheidung ob man vielleicht was
schöneres macht oder aber sich ein
personenschützer besorgt und sich dem
aussetzen will für mich persönlich
relativ leicht aber dass menschen vor
solchen entscheidungen stehen und sagen
ich fühle mich gefährdet in so einer
situation sagt ja schon sehr viel
darüber aus wie die stimmung in der
verschwörungs ideologischen szene und
auch in der rechtsextremen szene derzeit
ist was wir beobachten eben auch in
diversen per telegramm channels aber
auch anderen gruppen auf social media
ist dass wir ein
kalli sierung sehen also da sehen wir
eben menschen und gruppen die sich
zunehmend in ja so eine parallele
realität reinsteigern dass eine art
putsch eine art umsturz jeden moment
stattfinden könnte wobei das natürlich
eine wiederkehrende situation
beziehungsweise erzählung ist die auch
in der szene verbreitet wird ähnliche
diskussionen gab es im übrigen schon
anfang des sommers als das
infektionsschutzgesetz das letzte mal
eben von der bundesregierung diskutiert
wurde und auch damals wurden eben ganz
schreckliche schreckensszenarien an die
wand gemalt da gab es eben auch menschen
die verängstigt waren und das hat sich
dann ja als großer irrtum eben auch als
großer fake herausgestellt was dort an
ängsten verbreite fuhr dann fakt ist
dass ich mit vielen journalisten auch in
den letzten tagen gesprochen habe die
mir teilweise gesagt haben die art und
weise wie wir auf diesen demonstrationen
angegangen worden sind von
teilnehmerinnen und teilnehmer neben
nicht auch nur von menschen die man
jetzt ja visuell jetzt im rechtsextremen
spektrum einsortieren würde sondern auch
menschlich relativ durchschnittlich
normal aussehenden anführungszeichen das
war schon erschreckend und das geht über
das hinaus was man sonst bei
rechtsextremen demonstrationen sieht und
das erschreckende war auch das eben wenn
gegen journalisten geprügelt wurde
teilweise es zu handgreiflichkeiten
gekommen ist dann auch umstehende nicht
eingeschritten haben was eben auch ein
zeichen dafür ist dass dieses feindbild
von journalisten eben von
medienschaffenden etwas ist was auch
unterschiedliche milieus und auch
teilnehmende auf diesen demonstrationen
zunehmend vereint ich sehe hier im chat
da gibt es auch zwei richtungen die
einen wie zum beispiel johannes denen
über youtube sagen ich sehe in dem
auftritt der afd auf der straße einen
schulterschluss mit npd landi laufen da
auch mit das haben sie ja auch gerade
schon angedeutet auf der anderen seite
schreibt zum beispiel es punkt wurz über
youtube er behauptet gestern war keine
einzige querdenken demo in berlin das
waren keine gruppierungen das war
gestern der mittelstand und das normale
volk das angst um ihr grundgesetz hat
wird endlich auf friedliche bürger zu
diffamieren was sagen sie dazu
na ja fakt ist dass unterschiedliche
gruppierungen und auch bekannte
influenza dazu aufgerufen haben an
dieser demonstration teilzunehmen
fakt ist dass menschen auch sich quasi
auch für diese demonstration
stellvertretend hingestellt haben und
beispielsweise über forderungen
gesprochen haben
und da muss man das eben auch
dementsprechend einsortieren und
natürlich muss man sich auch ein bild
davon machen wie sie es auf der demo aus
was für slogans werden dort mit gerufen
was wir plakate werden dort in die luft
gehalten da muss man einfach schon sagen
da sieht man sehr stark das ist eine
prägung ist die die eben auch bei
anderen demonstrationen in den letzten
monaten gesehen haben also dieses
verschwörungs ideologische element ist
eben eine gemeinsamkeit die ganz viele
unterschiedliche milieus vereint eben
von der esoterik bis hin in die
rechtsextreme szene bis hin zu menschen
die vorher politisch überhaupt nicht
engagiert waren wo sich selbst auch in
keine schublade einsortieren würden fakt
ist aber dass sie inhalte mit tragen
indem sie auf solchen demonstrationen
mit laufen die da eben sind das sehr
starke feindbilder konstruiert werden
die auch aus meiner sicht
gesellschaftlich durchaus brisanz haben
weil wenn eben hass geschürt wird in
einer art und weise wie wir sie auf
diesen demonstrationen sehen gegen
journalisten und auch gegen
politikerinnen und politiker wie wir es
eben auch an den bildern im bundestag
gesehen haben dann führt das eben auch
zu einer verrohung der debatte ja und
wenn ich jemanden in einer debatte als
feindlich markiere als teil einer
verschwörung dann bin ich auch nicht
mehr daran interessiert miteinander ins
gespräch zu kommen und das ist eben die
große gefahr der radikalisierung dieser
gruppen die ich sehe dass man überhaupt
nicht mehr sachlich diskutieren kann
die könnte man jetzt beispielsweise
corona maßnahmen anpassen entschärfen
auch unterschiedliche bedürfnisse
eingehen und man muss auch sagen weiten
teilen derjenigen die zu diesen
demonstrationen aufrufen geht es auch
überhaupt nicht mehr um die korona
maßnahmen so würd ich das jedenfalls
einschätzen
also wenn man schon bürgerkriegs
fantasien schreibt wenn man darüber
spricht dass man das grundgesetz
abschaffen will dann ist man ja längst
jenseits davon wie geht man denn damit
um zum einen im privaten umfeld wenn man
jemanden hat er sagt ich bin dieser
meinung
ich fahre nach berlin ich fand das gut
diese aktion die da gemacht wurden
wie geht man damit um und wie gibt wie
kann die politik damit umgehen ja
zunächst einmal glaube ich dass wir
wirklich eine sehr breite debatte in der
gesellschaft darüber brauchen wir mit
dieser pandemie umgehen es gibt ja nicht
die eine lösung und wir brauchen eben
eine breite debatte aber klar muss sein
das ist auch so etwas wie fakten gibt ja
irgendwer leugnet das von corona in
irgendeiner form eine gefahr für die
gesundheit der bevölkerung ausgehen
würde der leugnet dass es eben zu
überlastung erscheinen im
gesundheitssystem kommen kann
er ignoriert einfach alles was wir eben
in den letzten monaten auch mit hinblick
auf andere länder gelernt haben und was
auch die wissenschaft sagen da muss man
auch irgendwo unterscheidung zwischen
berechtigter kritik an maßnahmen und
einfach auch verschwörungs ideologischen
denken und wenn man jemanden im
freundeskreis und familienumfeld hat der
ja zunehmend soll ich mal inhalte
vielleicht verbreitet in whatsapp
gruppen oder auch im gespräch mit der
familie wo man denkt das hört sich jetzt
nach verschwörungs erzählung an da würde
ich immer dazu raten
gehen sie darauf ein schweigen sie nicht
dazu gehen sie nicht darüber hinweg als
wäre nichts gewesen weil schweigen wird
oft als zustimmung interpretiert und
gegenrede hat auch noch einen weiteren
effekt also sie werden vielleicht nicht
im ersten gespräch jemanden überzeugen
können aber sie können zweifel säen und
vor allem können sie ein signal an
andere zu hörende an mitlesen de
schicken dass sie eben zeigen so hätten
nicht jeder stimmt dem zu und es gibt
durchaus begründete zweifel an diesen
aussagen hier ist beispielsweise ein
ding zu einem faktencheck
wenn man allerdings merkt dass jemand
schon sage ich mal zunehmend
radikalisiert ist beispielsweise von
einer großen verschwörung am in medien
und wissenschaft spricht auch nicht mehr
empfänglich ist beispielsweise für
wissenschaftliche studien weil er oder
sie glaubt dass die stecken und hat alle
unter einer decke im rahmen einer
verschwörung dann würde ich wirklich
dazu raten im gespräch unter vier augen
zu gehen und das wirklich auch als
langfristiges projekt zu sehen dass man
nicht in einem gespräch lösen kann ja
also genauso lange wie der weg der
radikalisierung dauert dauert es oft bis
jemand eben aus diesem kaninchenbau von
ideologien wieder herausfindet und man
muss sich auch immer klar machen dass
manchmal auch ängste da hängt da stehen
also wir wissen aus der
wissenschaftlichen forschung das
situation des kontrollverlusts menschen
empfänglich machen für den glauben an
solche negative weil sie eben uns
sozusagen um wo halt geben ja eine
erklärung und auch klare feindbilder und
das ist irgendwo verlockend für menschen
die gerade auch sehr viel durchmachen
und da macht es auch sinn mal zu fragen
hey wie gehts dir eigentlich kann ich
dir irgendwie helfen weil manchmal ist
vielleicht der auslöser der dazu geführt
hat dass menschen sich ein solches
fantasiewelten irgendwo auch rein
flüchten
manchmal ist der auslöser ganz anderer
natur und hat überhaupt nichts mit
politik zu tun
die diskussion hier im netz die da
funktioniert der austausch ganz gut und
so weit ich das beurteilen kann
funktioniert es auch sehr sachlich und
konstruktiv was ich echt schön finde
weil das genau der rahmen ist in dem wir
miteinander diskutieren wollen und genau
deshalb machen wir auch diese sendung
eine frage kommt über youtube von
patrick der fragt genau an sie die frage
wie schätzt frauen nun die querdenker
szene ein
denken sie dass die meisten bereits im
radikalen bis extremistischen bereich
vor corona unterwegs waren ja so da kann
man nur mutmaßen und da fehlen auch noch
wissenschaftliche studien jetzt sage ich
mal in der breite sich angeschaut haben
was wie sieht es - von den leuten die
jetzt einfach zu einer demo gehen oder
einfach die talibangruppe abonniert
haben wobei man sagen muss das ist auch
ein schwieriges forschungsfeld weil
nicht jeder unbedingt der an eine große
wissenschafts verschwörung glaubt
vielleicht lust hat mit wissenschaftler
darüber zu sprechen warum er in der
jeweiligen gruppe ist aber wir sehen
eben dass zumindest teile dieser szene
oder auch lokale gruppen aus diesen
bündnissen durchaus starke verbindungen
eben haben zum verschwörungs
ideologischen milieu zum impfgegner
milieu wo auch verschwörungs mitteln
schon immer eine große rolle gespielt
haben und eben auch zur rechtsextremen
szene bis hin zu einzelnen lokalen
demonstrationen die eben auch von
menschen angemeldet wurden die auch
ganze jahr auf die parteigänger oder
sogar afd funktionäre sind und da muss
man sagen gab es schon immer
eine sehr starke verbindung wobei man
auch dazusagen muss die verschwörungs
ideologisches den hatte schon immer sehr
starke überschneidungen mit der
rechtsextremen szene also es gibt
mehrere magazine die man also die
bundesweit auch beispielsweise an
bahnhöfen verkauft werden die teilweise
auch eine recht hohe auflage erreichen
wo alle möglichen mythen über mode
landung des mord an jay kay was auch
immer berichtet werden die jetzt auf
diesen corona zug aufgesprungen sind und
die auch schon immer rechtsextremisten
raum gegeben haben
und von daher ist es auch keine
überraschung für mich dass da eben genau
diese mischung auch auf den
demonstrationen auftritt und erklärungen
zum thema abgrenzung aus dem
rechtsextremen milieu halte ich eben von
unterschiedlichen bündnissen für extrem
unglaubwürdig solange man eben auch
nachweislich weiß dass führen dass
figuren beispielsweise ein
pressesprecher verbindung ins reich
mitbürger medien haben einen raise
bürgervereinen in der vergangenheit mit
gegründet haben also eine glaubwürdige
distanzierung sieht ja auch anders aus
ich würde gern noch mal in den bundestag
hineinschauen das was im bundestag
passiert ist und was wir zu beginn
dieser sendung thematisiert haben diese
videos das ist ja relativ eindeutig weil
sie alle mit handys in der hand da
unterwegs waren und das ja auch zum teil
live gestreamt haben das war eine aktion
die dazu gedacht war
öffentlichkeitswirksam im netz
publiziert zu werden
sobald man das sagen kann ich würde
behaupten zum jetzigen zeitpunkt kann
man das ziemlich gesichert behaupten
welche wirkung hat eine solche aktion ja
sowas sehr interessant ist an diesen
unterschiedlichen gruppierungen ist dass
sie nicht im klassischen stil
organisiert sind in vereinen oder sage
ich mal in parteien also all diese
gruppierung spielen auch eine rolle aber
eine große rolle spielen auch influenza
also menschen mit eigenen youtube
kanälen mit eigenen teile channels die
eben auch ein großes interesse daran
haben reichweite aufzubauen ja und wie
baut man reichweite auf eine option ist
eben dass man durchgängig soll ich mal
versucht auch skandale zu liefern dass
man versucht möglichst radikale aktionen
zu filmen alles gehabt
auch sogenannte flashmobs in berlin wo
gruppen von männern
auch mit livestream ins internet in die
s-bahn gestiegen sind
ohne maske leute angepöbelt haben dass
die maske abnehmen sollen dann auch
durchs einkaufszentrum gelaufen sind
was auch sehr viele leute verstört hat
muss man sagen also stellen sie sich mal
vor sie kommen müde von der arbeit nach
hause und sie werden dann beschimpft sie
sollen die maske abnehmen und sie wollen
einfach nur nach hause und mich
angesteckt werden ja und das heißt das
alles ist nicht neu das hat methode und
aus meiner sicht ist es auch höchst
unglaubwürdig dass eine partei wie die
fdp ja so eine nähe zu dieser szene hat
die sich da auch sehr gut auskennt die
auch diese methoden sehr gut kennt
jemanden eingeht dann unbewacht durch
den bundestag laufen lässt und dann
hinterher verkündete das haben wir nicht
gewusst
damit hätten wir nicht gerechnet also
ganz ehrlich mit verlaub das ist
vollkommen unglaubwürdig und ich halte
das auch schon eine wichtige diskussion
dass man jetzt schaut wie man damit
umgeht denn man darf ja nicht vergessen
dass viele der abgeordneten in den
letzten wochen und monaten zunehmend
auch mit drohungen aus dem verschwörungs
ideologischen milieu beim konfrontiert
sind das heißt in dem moment wo ein
wildfremder mensch mit einer kamera vor
ihnen steht und sie anpöbeln und sie
gerade auch keinen sicherheitsdienst
dabei haben da sind sich überhaupt nicht
sicher wird er mich angreifen will ja
nur filmen will ja nicht nur interview
oder sollte ich lieber reißaus nehmen
und aus meiner sicht ist das wirklich
schon eine massive störung der
parlamentsarbeit was glauben sie wie
entwickelt sich das weiter ja das ist
tatsächlich unglaublich spannend wie
sich das weiter entwickelt und aus
meiner sicht kann man das überhaupt
nicht vorhersagen es wird eben schon
angesprochen dass die fdp durchaus
gespalten ist und man sieht ja auch an
den umfragen dass die afg jetzt nicht
unbedingt in folge der unterstützung der
proteste bei den umfragen abhebt ja so
eine region ist ja durchaus das
gegenteil der fall
und mich alle abgeordneten stehen hinter
diesen kurs die zweite baustelle sind
die bündnisse selbst da gibt es große
konflikte zwischen einzelnen gruppen
hier einzelne gruppen sagen
beispielsweise wir müssen uns von
rechtsextremisten distanzieren andere
gruppierungen sage nein bei uns müssen
alle mittel hoffen wir lassen uns nicht
spalten auch reis bürger müssen bei uns
mit dabei sein können und da gibt es
eben ganz unterschiedliche diskussionen
und auch zwischen den instanzen und
dann gibt's übrigen konflikte man ist
sich ja nicht einig und man hat ja auch
durchaus unterschiedliche vorstellungen
von dem wie die realität angeblich
aussieht also auch unterschiedliche
verschwörungs mythen die miteinander
konkurrieren
und am ende des tages spielt auch das
ego von einigen influence an eine rolle
also da erlebt man teilweise in den
telegrammen channels wüsteste tiraden
einzelne akteure die sich gegenseitig
beschimpfen teil einer verschwörung zu
sein
das scheint wohl eine beliebte
abwehrstrategie gegen kritik zu sein
auch innerhalb der szene
ich möchte gerne eine frage aufgreifen
die hier aufgetaucht ist nämlich warum
wir die frau die den wirtschaftsminister
peter altmaier gefilmt hat eingangs als
rechte bezeichnet haben das haben wir
einfach deshalb gemacht weil sie auf
einladung der afg ganz offensichtlich im
bundestag war und nicht auf einladung
der linksfraktion das liegt also schon
nahe dass die politische übereinstimmung
in dieser richtung er groß ist eine
frage von stephen w möchte ich zum ende
noch aufgreifen
fraglich ist aber doch wieso die
regierung ist nicht schafft die
verschwörungs fakten zu entkräften frau
nur kuhn warum ist es so schwer diese
verschwörungstheorien oder wie steffen
weder so passen nennt verschwörungs
fakten einzuordnen und zu entkräften
tatsächlich ja hinter dieser frage
steckt glaube ist so ein bisschen die
annahme die viele von uns haben wenn wir
in diskussionen reingehen ja wir glauben
ja ganz oft wenn wir die beweise
vorlegen oder die fakten haben dann wird
wird unser gegenüber sich das anschauen
und einsehen ich bin um recht und wird
einlenken ja aber wir alle kennen das
doch aus diskussionen auch im privaten
umfeld das manchmal beim menschen sich
sehr stark auf einer sache ja versteifen
und vielleicht auch sehr stark da
öffentlich darauf beharrt haben dass
ihre position ist dass es auch mit
gesichtsverlust zu tun hat sich
einzugestehen dass man sich geirrt hat
und manchmal verrenken sich menschen
auch in einem glauben an eine bestimmte
ideologie und gerade in der medialen
diskussion
ein verschwörungs ideologien gibt es
ziemlich viele fallstricke also was ich
problematisch fand in den letzten
monaten vor allem am anfang der panini
war dass viele verschwörung sind im trap
produziert wurden da wird teilweise in
so einem boulevard stil darüber
berichtet am schau mal was dieser b
promi glaubt wird ausführlich erzählt
was er glaubt und dann noch sein
telegramm channel genannt und damit hat
man eben auch diese akteure bekanntheit
und 8 und man hat eben auch ein podium
geboten für menschen die mit verlaub zum
thema coruna und biologie überhaupt gar
keine kompetenz haben und da ihre
verschwörungs ideologien verbreitet
haben
und auch also ich glaube auch dass wir
das besser für die zukunft hinkriegen
kann dass wir auch besser drauf schauen
können wie diskurse aufgebaut sind und
dass man beispielsweise stärker man
faktenchecks arbeitet und stärker schaut
wie also muss man unbedingt inhalte von
verschwörungstheorien wiederholen oder
stellt man sie eher richtig ja aber ich
glaube auch dass geht das phänomen nicht
wegbekommen werden und das wissen wir
eben auch aus der wissenschaftlichen
forschung es gibt einen gewissen
prozentsatz von menschen die werden
immer an verschwörungen glauben egal wie
transparent beispielsweise staatliche
institutionen sind und egal wie klar die
wissenschaftliche faktenlage ist und das
sieht man ja auch sehr gut an der
diskussion um den klimawandel ja also
99,9 prozent der wissenschaftler sind
sich absolut einig und das schon seit
jahrzehnten dass wir auch eine globale
katastrophe hinstellen und trotzdem gibt
es eben in vielen ländern also an allen
ländern eigentlichen gewissen
prozentsatz frau stabil über 5 prozent
in manchen ländern über zehn prozent die
den menschengemachten klimawandel
leugnen frau nun ich danke ihnen an
dieser stelle ganz herzlich dafür dass
sie das heute abend mit uns eingeschätzt
haben und möchte ganz zum schluss noch
etwas aufnehmen von coop kompendium 17
01 über youtube zum thema andere
störaktionen
dort schreibt jemand linke störaktionen
die von greenpeace werden vom zdf
begrüßt und bejubelt insofern die
übliche linke doppelmoral beim zdf
hierzu verweise ich sehr gerne auf die
heute de die nehme ich einen
umfangreichen artikel dazu
veröffentlicht hat heute
welche sachen im bundestag erlaubt sind
welche sachen nicht erlaubt sind und
welche aktionen zum beispiel im
bundestag stattgefunden haben
protestaktionen etwa am 27 april 2007 da
hat jemand gefälschte geldscheine von
der besuchertribüne geworfen waren linke
aktivisten es gab jetzt zuletzt am
zweiten juli 2020 von klimaaktivisten
von extension rebellion der aktion am
bundestag über die wir auch berichtet
haben und natürlich muss man
zusammenfassend feststellen dass es noch
einmal ein unterschied macht ob
abgeordnete im reichstag bedrängt werden
oder nicht
aufklärung bietet hier natürlich immer
das programm des zdf und wie gesagt die
heute de ich danke ganz herzlich fürs
mitmachen kommentieren fragen und zu
schauen und wünsche ihnen und euch noch
einen schönen abend tschüss